se a abc un triángulo tal que el ángulo
acb es igual a pi sextos entonces para
empezar muy bien este problema vamos a
empezar dibujando nuestro triángulo
tenemos aquí nuestro triángulo no
importa cómo se vea el triángulo
realmente solo es para darnos una idea
de cómo podemos resolver el problema y
tenemos aquí los vértices digamos a b y
c y nos dicen que el ángulo acb es decir
el que va de a c y luego ve este ángulo
mide y sextos y por supuesto estamos
hablando en radiales y sextos son 180
entre 6 son 30 grados por si no estás
tan familiarizado con los radiales ahora
dice de notemos por a b y c a las
longitudes de los lados opuestos a b y c
respectivamente entonces este es el lado
opuesto es este y este es a éste será b
y esteras este será c ok y nos preguntan
cuál es o cuáles son los valores de x
para los cuales se cumplen esta relación
muy bien entonces tenemos que relacionar
dice con nuestro ángulo pi sextos y para
poder hacer eso después tendremos que
resolver para x y ver si coincide con
uno o varios de estos valores que nos
dan ok entonces para relacionar a b y c
y un ángulo inmediatamente debe estar
saltando en tu cabeza una ley
fundamental de la geometría y que es la
ley de cosenos verdad la ley de cosenos
ley de cosenos y esencialmente lo que
nos dice la ley de cosenos es lo
siguiente que se cuadrada es cuadrada
más b cuadrada menos o que ese es el
teorema de pitágoras pero corregido
verdad con un -2 ave por el coseno del
ángulo c mayúscula muy bien en este caso
nuestro ángulo sé que corresponde al
alam al ángulo que está digamos en el
vértice s éste es de 30 grados ok
entonces la ley de de cosenos es un
teorema de pitágoras corregido ahora sí
que si queremos aplicar la ley de
cosenos a nuestro nuestro ejemplo
particular pues vamos a sustituirlo
aquí tenemos se cuadrada es igual a a
cuadrada más b cuadrada menos 2 ave y el
coseno de 30 grados con cuál es el
coseno de 30 grados a ver vamos a ver
si vamos a resolver la prueba digamos
del ite pues necesitamos tener todas
nuestras herramientas al alcance porque
es un examen bastante complicado verdad
y además hay un tiempo ahí que puede
estar nos presionando entonces tenemos
este triángulo si le ponemos este
hipotenusa 1 a este 30 grados este es de
90 por supuesto este será de 60 grados
lo que sabemos es que el cateto opuesto
entre la hipotenusa es el seno y el seno
de 30 grados es un medio por lo tanto el
coche no tiene que ser raíz de 3 entre 2
para que funcione el teorema de
pitágoras verdad entonces el coseno
en realidad estamos hablando de el
coseno de 30 grados es cateto adyacente
entre hipotenusa que es raíz de 3 entre
2 entonces aquí multiplicamos por la
raíz de 3 entre 2 y lo que pasa aquí es
que los dos se cancelan entonces lo que
concluimos es que se cuadrada será igual
a cuadrada + b cuadrada menos la raíz de
3 por ave muy bien y esto es ya como
estamos relacionando nuestro ángulo de
pi sextos con los lados a y b a b y c de
hecho ok entonces aquí pues uno podría
por ejemplo sustituir a b y c y tratar
de resolver para x pero si nos damos
cuenta se cuadra bueno a cuadrada ya es
un polinomio de orden 4 y le le sumamos
un polinomio que sería b cuadrada
el cuadrado de esto sería un polinomio
de orden 4 también entonces sería como
una especie de ecuación de orden 4
entonces eso hizo que en general cuando
uno está resolviendo un examen pues un
examen occidental recordemos que el ite
es un examen para entrar a universidades
en india pero al menos en los occidente
en los exámenes occidentales que yo he
visto cuando uno se complican las
operaciones pues significa que algo ya
estamos haciendo malo o que el punto es
encontrar un truco o la elegancia del
problema de cómo resolverlo cuando uno
lo encuentra generalmente ya el problema
sale casi directo ok pero en este caso
en élite hay que no solo hay que hallar
un truco hay que hacer muchas cuentas
muchas operaciones hay que utilizar
todos los trucos posibles que estén a
nuestro alcance y digo yo yo nunca
presenté el té pero bueno pues a medida
que estaba haciendo estos ejercicios me
he dado cuenta de que de que son más
crueles a la hora de aplicar este examen
allá en india que los exámenes
tradicionales de occidente
y digo yo no crecí en india entonces
pero bueno el punto es que estos
exámenes tienden a ser un poco más
complicados y hay que hallar un truco
para resolver el problema muy bien aquí
un truco que podemos hacer es tratar de
despejar el término ave como le vamos a
hacer pues vamos a sumar de ambos lados
de la igualdad la raíz de 3 por ave
sumamos a y acá también sumamos la raíz
de 3 ave
ok sumamos eso y para despejar esto
vamos a restar se cuadrada de ambos
lados vamos a restar se cuadrada de
ambos lados muy bien y entonces lo que
nos queda es que estos dos se cancelan y
estos se cancelan y finalmente me queda
me queda la raíz de 3 por ave es igual y
vamos a copiar
tenemos a cuadrada más be cuadrada
- menos se cuadrada menos se cuadrada ok
y entonces todavía podemos dividir esto
entre ave
vivimos de ambos lados entre ave
a ambos lados de entre ave y esto nos va
a dar una una respuesta una primera
aproximación de cómo hacer este problema
entonces bueno podría seguir pero
ahorita sí quiero ver quién esa cuadrada
de cuadrada y se cuadrada porque aquí
tenemos que operar los verdad tenemos
que operar estas son más de la cuadrada
de cuadrada y restarle después se
cuadrada después vamos a ir viendo cómo
se puede ir resolviendo el problema ok
bueno entonces vamos vamos a armarnos de
paciencia y ver esto entonces a cuadrada
quien es a cuadrada pues es x cuadrada
más x más 1 verdad eso era eso era lo
que teníamos acá arriba
y aquí está
y cuadrada bueno aquí está hay que
calcular a cuadrada y lo puedo elevar al
cuadrado o bien hacer la multiplicación
de esto consigo mismo verdad aquí es en
donde en la prueba nos están evaluando
qué tan sabemos multiplicar polinomios
entonces agarramos el 1 y multiplicamos
todo esto nos da x cuadrada más x más 1
luego tomamos xy multiplicamos todo esto
x por 1 x tenemos x x x x cuadrada x x x
cuadrada es x al cubo y ahora x cuadrada
multiplica todo esto es x cuadrado por 1
es x cuadrada x cuadrada x xx al cubo y
x cuadrada por x cuadrada es x a la 4
entonces al resolver esto que es lo que
nos da nos da x a la cuatro más 2 x al
cubo más 3 x cuadrada más 2 x más 1 y
esto es a cuadrado entonces fue
engorroso quizás pero no tan complicado
muy bien ahora vamos a ver quiénes ve
cuadrada esto es más fácil porque b es x
cuadrada menos 1 entonces x cuadrado
menos 1 simplemente si lo elevamos al
cuadrado usamos
la fórmula de el binomio al cuadrado y
tenemos x a la 4 - 2x cuadrada más 1
verdad tengo un binomio lo elevamos al
cuadrado es el cuadrado de este más el
doble de este x este más el segundo al
cuadrado
y ahora vamos a ver quiénes se cuadrada
se cuadrada y vamos a ponerlo digamos
con este color aquí esta c entonces se
cuadrada simplemente va a ser otra vez
utilizando la fórmula de un binomio al
cuadrado es 4x al cuadrado
dos veces 2x por 1 que es 4x más el
cuadrado de 1 que es uno muy bien
entonces ya tenemos al cuadrado de
cuadrada y se cuadrada entonces si si si
queremos resolver esto tenemos la raíz
de 3 será igual a
y bueno vamos a hacer a cuadrada más de
cuadrada menos se cuadrada vamos a
hacerlo aquí mismo si sumamos a cuadrada
con x a la 4
22 x al cuadrado más 1 y además vamos a
sumar 4x cuadrada más 4x
no estamos restando verdad entonces aquí
son menos
4x y porque estamos restando se cuadrada
si restamos este y restamos 1 que es lo
que nos da tenemos equis cuarta más x
cuarta son 2 voy a ponerlo con azul esto
es 2 x a la 4 esto se sigue igual más 2
x al cubo y aquí tenemos 3 x cuadrada
menos 6 x cuadrada entonces tenemos
menos seis más tres son menos tres x
cuadrada aquí tenemos dos x menos 4 x
son menos 2x y tenemos dos menos uno y
eso es más uno entonces la raíz de tres
simplemente la parte de arriba es 2x a
la 4 más 2 x al cubo menos 3 x cuadrada
menos 2 x + 1 y todo esto va dividido
entre a por b a por b que es x cuadrada
más x + 1 esto es a
luego multiplicamos por ver pero ve era
x cuadrada menos 1 verdad
entonces hasta aquí no quizás no he
logrado mucho por ejemplo si yo pasara
el divisor multiplican perdón en el
denominador multiplicando a raíz de 3 y
luego lo pasara del lado derecho
nuevamente tendría un un polinomio de
orden 4 que tengo que resolver es una
ecuación de orden 4 y eso es muy
complicado pero la forma en cómo lo
escribimos ahorita me da mucha mucha
sensación mucho sabor mucha esperanza de
que podemos factorizar lo de arriba y
eso es porque tenemos coeficientes
enteros verdad 2 2 - 3 - 2 1 entonces
eso me da mucha esperanza de que podamos
factorizar y si hay factores comunes en
el numerador y en el denominador
entonces podemos reducir la complejidad
del problema al cancelar los verdad ahí
lo voy a dejar para no hacer un vídeo
tan largo y en el siguiente vamos a
tratar de factorizar en la parte de
arriba para resolver esta ecuación en x